[Music]
hey guys it's Jonah here who loves to
eat rice
hey I'm Asian of course I love rice rice
is so easy to cook it is versatile and
you know what rice can be very healthy
so I'm gonna share with you three rice
recipes which you can prep ahead and it
is perfect for your family dinner let's
start with a really simple recipe while
rice and bean salad so this recipe is
great as a starter or even as a main
meal so what I've used are one cup of
cooked and chilled wild rice you can use
any other rice of your choice have a can
of beans rinsed and drinked again choose
any beans of your choice half a red bell
pepper diced 1/2 a cup of cherry
tomatoes haft 1 small onion diced
quarter cup of corn quarter cup of
cucumber diced cut a cup of olives as
for the dressing you'll need 3
tablespoons of lemon juice 1 tablespoon
of olive oil 1/2 a teaspoon of maple
syrup 1/2 a teaspoon of smoked paprika
quarter teaspoon of cumin powder quarter
teaspoon of garlic powder and salt and
black pepper to taste in a small bowl
mix together all the dressing
ingredients and set aside to make the
salad all you have to do is assemble all
the ingredients in a bowl so let's start
with the rice as the base and all the
vegetables beans bell pepper cucumber
corn cherry tomatoes onion and olives
drizzle with a little bit of dressing
and serve it really is that simple when
you want to eat it simply toss all the
ingredients together this dish is so
colorful its nutritious and it is
absolutely delicious so this one huge
bowl of rice salad has about 305
calories plus it provides you with your
3 a day this dish is also great to be
eaten chilled so you can prep 3 to 4
servings and just
keep it in the fridge separate the
dressing to keep your salad fresh okay
I'm really excited about this next
recipe
I can't stop making it for dinner yep it
is the one pot fish and rice soup I love
soup and it goes perfectly with rice for
this recipe what you'll need are four
cups of broth chicken fish or vegetable
about 400 gram of Dori fish fillet or
any other fish fillet of your choice
half a cup of uncooked rice rinsed have
a can of beans rinsed and drained have a
can of diced tomatoes 1 teaspoon of
cumin powder one teaspoon of garlic
powder one teaspoon of cayenne pepper
one teaspoon of mixed herbs and one
teaspoon of salt
we want to start by prepping the rice so
feel a large pot with four cups of broth
and the uncooked rice cover bring to a
boil and allow the rice to almost cook
for about 25 to 30 minutes so you want
to adjust the cooking time depending on
the rice you're using once the rice is
almost ready let's stir in all the
ingredients fish beans diced tomatoes
corn and all the spices allow all the
ingredients to simmer for another 10 to
15 minutes until the fish and rice are
fully cooked and the soup thickens
slightly don't forget to stir
occasionally serve hot I love this
recipe because it is so versatile you
can simply change the ingredients
according to what's available
this dish is also very high in protein
so it is a great post-workout meal one
serving has about 360 calories and 28
grams of protein plus soups fill you up
very quickly so it is a great dish if
you're watching your waist line
you know what I love it when I can use
the same recipe change it a little bit
and create a whole new dish so for my
final recipe we're going to use what we
have cooked and create stuffed bell
pepper rice here's what we're going to
do preheat the oven to 180 degrees
Celsius let's start by prepping the bell
peppers cut the top part of the bell
peppers and scoop up the seeds to create
a pocket we want to feel each bell
pepper with the rice mixture from the
previous recipe fill them up without at
the soup and set aside next fill up the
bottom of a baking dish with thickly
sliced potato and carrots you want to
keep them as leveled and flat as
possible then place the stuffed bell
peppers on top so the potatoes and
carrots will help prevent the bell
peppers from burning at the bottom then
simply pull the fish and rice soup over
the potatoes and carrots cover the bell
peppers and bake for 30 to 40 minutes
until the bell peppers are soft and
slightly roasted voila
look at that it is so pretty and it
tastes absolutely yummy and it will
impress your family and friends as well
so one bell peppers stuffed with rice
has about 288 calories you can ever
staff tomatoes aubergines or zucchinis
again this recipe is extremely versatile
you can choose to melt some cheese on
top if you want to or if you're a vegan
then replace the fish with tofu or
tempeh give all these recipes a try
make them let me know which is your
favorite in the comments below take
pictures and tack me at Jonas our
official hashtag adjacent recipes
because I want to see your creation
don't forget to like this video share
this recipe with your friends and
subscribe to my youtube channel for a
lot more delicious and healthy recipes
guys turn on your notification button so
that you won't get notified every time I
share a new video all the best